question i hear pretty frequently is
which programming
language should i learn what's the best
programming language
in 2021 or should i learn
well for me it's c plus plus because
that's what i'm usually using
should i learn in 2021 and i have the
answer for you
the definitive answer probably the only
answers so
if you hear other stuff i'm guessing
just guessing
that they are probably wrong
all right the answer is really simple
first of all welcome to code tech
tutorials my name is matt i am a c plus
plus coder and uh someone who works on
game engines and various tools and makes
tutorials
stuff like that so if you like code and
stuff
and technology consider subscribing
today all right i'll get right to it
here
is the simple answer of
what language you should learn
well that's not the question to be
asking i think
so rather than what language should you
learn the question is more along
what are you trying to accomplish
because you have to think
of programming languages as a tool when
they were
all originally created they served some
purpose
people weren't just making them to be
cool or making them to
well maybe some of them were but for the
most part all the practical ones that
people actually use were made to serve a
purpose
and the purpose is often just memory
management
and accomplishing what you want with the
software i guess
just putting up fingers randomly here so
i think
the bottom line is that you should be
asking the question
what am i trying to accomplish and if
you're not sure
then it might be an okay idea to just
sift through a few languages
do the hello world see which one you
kind of like
also read the pros and cons there are
lots of websites out there
and lots of information out there about
each language
for example here i just did a quick
google search of pros and cons
programming languages and a bunch of
different articles come up a bunch of
different suggestions come up
and you can kind of get an idea of what
might be best
based on things like this even
and you know you might have to take
these with a little grain of salt you
never know how accurate
someone is on the line but
all right let's take a look what are the
pros cons and uses of major programming
languages what programming language
should i learn ah here we go
i wanted a general overview of what
certain languages are used for what is
good bad easy hard high maintenance or
low maintenance
okay here we go this is good i like that
this guy expanded because when people
just simply ask what programming
language should i
learn that's such an open-ended question
with so many follow-up questions
and the main follow-up questions usually
are what are you trying to do what's
important to you do you like
meticulous control because that would be
like c
c plus plus if you don't care so much
about that and you just want it to work
python or java might be better
okay so here's an answer from eight
years ago let's see if it's still
relevant from dan tayo a software
engineer
high level overly generalized answer
okay
so he clarifies that yeah it's really
hard to like
pinpoint each but looks like he's got a
good write up so we're going to go
through them today
like for going through the languages and
i will give my opinion of what he says
too
i'm guessing he's pretty close to right
given that he's the most uploaded one
all right cc plus plus plus best
generally used for low
level system stuff operating systems ice
drivers
also very popular for game development
as well the linux community
potential cons very low level not ideal
for development of ordinary applications
and seldom used
for web development okay i can
see how that's kind of makes sense not
ideal for developing ordinary
applications
i kind of use it for ordinary
applications
but yeah like if you go and try to do
android programming or you're going to
be recommended java it really pushes you
towards java if you do
uh apple like iphone development
i think they push you pretty hard
towards go or swift
so yeah definitely
uh device drivers and game development
are the big things i would say for c but
it is fine for ordinary applications in
my opinion you can get some of the best
performance
possible all right let's go to the next
one java the most popular language
overall
widely used for enterprise applications
web applications
i wouldn't personally recommended it
i pro i've used java quite a bit so i
did android programming for a few years
or about a full year uh non-stop
basically and
i kind of got used to it and it's not
too bad
the in general it's kind of easy to get
stuff
done all right potential cons not very
sexy fairly boring in terms of language
features somewhat old-fashioned
i don't know it seemed okay um
i didn't really have any big complaints
if the code was maybe a little more
it felt like it was a little bit more
than it needed to be like it's a little
bit verbose maybe
other than that i didn't really mind
okay.net primarily c sharp
similar to java but not widely used i
actually really like c-sharp but
wouldn't recommend it unless you have
specific
need to learn.net potential cons
perceived by many as a java clone
used in same scenarios java but not
widely used
c sharp this is kind of an old answer c
is also used for a lot of game
development these days
unity may use it as their main scripting
language
who knows it might get like translated
to something else behind the scenes
or something like that but in general
java and net are considered similar
because they use a
jit compiler or a jit compiler
sometimes also known as a so what is a
jit compiler you ask
just in time compiler feature of a
runtime
interpreter so
with jit compilers you get runtime
performance it's kind of like it's sort
of like compiling every time
you run it it's that's simple right over
you can read more about it
but it's generally pretty slow to launch
things written in these languages
because it does this just in time
compiling so those languages can often
be
seen as a little slower for that reason
all right let's read on i'm a little
less familiar with these
leftover languages so i'm not going to
have as much
insight prime okay objective c primarily
popular again because of
ios related to c plus plus c c plus plus
but some very different syntax mixed in
potential cons very
narrow applicability
but don't make no mistake ios is pretty
big
reason to learn it okay it looks like
it's mainly an ios thing i've never used
objective-c so i can't really comment on
it
ruby very popular and cool especially in
the startup community i think
this answer is pretty old i don't think
ruby's very cool anymore
uh great for writing web applications
using rails usually popular framework
and other relay
frameworks exist
uh better than java for creating web
applications quickly potential cons fast
moving language launches validate online
documentation and this was out years ago
eight years ago so not really useful for
developing
gui applications oddly enough like when
i have these headphones on
makes it harder for me to speak because
i can't hear myself it's like i'm deaf
all right so i feel like i slur
words more when i have them off or on
all right python similar to ruby and
above ways though seemingly not as
popular
i think it's probably more popular now
many python users will swear by its
superiority as a language
yeah uh it usually the syntax is pretty
nice
it's less verbose than like every other
language pretty much
well at least the big ones like all
these
uh so that's i think where python
wins a lot of points khan's not
exceptionally popular language in the
industry
i don't know it's not i feel like it's
kind of popular in an
industry now i think it's picked up a
lot php
uh people a language that people love to
hate
widely ubiquitous but considered many to
by many to be terrible poorly designed
language that said
using a huge number of successful
websites
yeah i don't really i've never really
used i've used a tiny bit of php i like
learn some basic syntax at one point but
that's really it i've never made an
application php i can't really comment
but i know
some people that kind of swear by it and
say like you can't go wrong if you want
to do web stuff
to learn php javascript okay well
clearly this guy's biased right off the
bat he starts out with amazing language
rather than you know the facts about it
all right that seems to be in the middle
of a renaissance formerly used in
client-side functionality
but now also used in side potential cons
considered a toy language by some
still used for most browser side
functionality
well um i think this guy
seems a little biased he's probably a
web developer that's really good at
javascript
i can't really comment to be honest i
don't think i've ever designed an app
that actually used
javascript i always use c or c plus plus
or java
use a little bit of c sharp and use a
little bit of python
but javascript okay i've copied and
pasted javascript i have done a few
websites
and i needed some special features and i
used javascript to do it but i didn't
really know what was going on
also took some courses in javascript uh
when i was a new coder and just kind of
trying to get used to some of the
languages a little bit
i did those on code academy which is
this
website right here this is a great
website for
sort of getting your feet wet with
languages and kind of learning the basic
syntax of how they work
you're not going to get to expert level
on
this site or any site or really any
instruction
any anyway
but the point is i do know a little
javascript i just didn't find it
i didn't like the syntax personally i
get that once i get used to it it would
be better
and i'm just really used to c and c plus
plus but you're kind of making lambdas
all over the place with javascript so
once i learned lambda and cnc plus plus
suddenly like javascript javascript
clicked for me
a little more but i don't see much use
for
usually everything it can do application
wise
a different language is kind of better
in my opinion just based on the
performance you can get
but if you're doing web development you
still can't really
go wrong with knowing jobs from
javascript you kind of have to
just dive in make some web apps and get
good at it the only way to become an
expert at any of these languages
is to use it a bunch so keep that in
mind
okay so that was just kind of hitting a
google search and giving my opinion on
it
so what do you think is the best
language to learn and under what
situations
it's pretty common for people to say c
and c
plus for game development you must learn
them and there are lots of stories about
that i think one big recent one is uh
there was this game okay so this is the
kind of story
you know there's these mmo scam videos
that people make about
mmos that are clearly not what they seem
to be and chronicles of valyria is a
really interesting
one because this one i think part of the
reason it accidentally became a scam i
don't think they purposely made it a
scam i think the
creator probably had good intentions you
can make your own judgment i don't care
but the point i want to get to here is
if you listen to the dev talk he talks
about switching languages and it's
setting him back
so he didn't start with c plus plus
making this i think he started with
javascript or something some weird
language
uh for games that you probably shouldn't
be using for like a you know
actual release of anything big
so he started with one language and i
guess he hit roblox from what i
understand
and he had to switch to another language
and just rewriting everything sent him
back so it would have been better for
him
to pick the right language to begin with
um so if you want to like hear more
about that you can watch the videos but
people now consider it a scam because
it's been in the making for so
so long and uh i'm not going to comment
on whether it is or
isn't i don't i don't personally care i
have never really
been interested in the game to begin
with or
you know i only play a very specific set
of games in general
i'm not a big gamer anymore i used to be
a big gamer growing up was very
passionate about it but
these days i kind of just play a couple
different games in the downtime or to
relax
you can always look up how a game's made
if you're interested
if there's a game you really like or how
it's done you can always look up what
engine it's made in
what programming language they learn the
developers are usually pretty open about
talking about that kind of stuff once
the game's out
so more insight there and of course
whatever you're interested in maybe
you're not interested in games
you can always search for whatever you
want how it's made
and get some ideas of of how they did it
and oftentimes if you want to make
something similar
they had good reasons for picking the
language you can kind of follow along
and be like aha
okay here we go and there you go so
that's how
you pick a language
i do believe that you probably shouldn't
be over
analyzing this it's best to just find a
project
and then get into a language as a tool
see what it can do see how easy it is to
use and if it's not the right one for
you
do a little more digging and pick
something else they all have their pros
and cons
and you can't just blanket save ones
better than the other
is the point well i hope you enjoyed the
video
thanks for watching and i'll see you
guys next time
peace out
[Music]
so
hmm
[Music]
me
[Music]
you